these low-income workers in Islamabad
scrambled to buy a bag of
government-subsidized flour inflation
disproportionately affects the poorest
in society
[Music]
across Pakistan many are struggling with
the rising cost of living it's been
hugely difficult to live on our earnings
I'm a daily laborer I have to queue up
for up to three hours to purchase
subsidized flour the regular prices are
unaffordable
soaring inflation is just one challenge
Pakistan is also facing a foreign
exchange crisis
these importers are protesting outside a
bank about a shortage of dollars they
can't get credit to pay for the goods
they're importing it means thousands of
containers packed with essential food
items raw materials and medical
equipment are stuck at the port in
Karachi
we demand the government immediately
provide dollars so that we can get our
Consignment release from the port and
prevent huge losses in shipping fees
importers who've been in the business
for 35 years say they've never seen it
this bad
we have barely 25 days of stock left if
the dollars are not released immediately
there'll be an immense shortage of grain
during Ramadan meaning further hardship
Pakistan is still recovering from last
year's historic Flooding at its peak
more than one-third of the country was
underwater at least 1700 people died and
damages are estimated at nearly 40
billion dollars last week the United
Arab Emirates agreed to defer the
repayment of 2 billion loan and provide
an extra one billion dollars but with
the national debt running at nearly 90
percent of GDP Pakistan is appealing for
more help from the global Community
Victoria Gayton B Al Jazeera